[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back we got a hot guest how you
doing judd i'm happy to be here couldn't
be happier you you called today yeah and
you texted and you said are you free and
i was i'm not i'm usually not even in
new york yeah and just i saw you doing
something at the 92nd street wine i was
like judd's a new and give the new book
so that's right i'll be there tomorrow
with rami yusuf
we love romney you can go does this run
before that no yeah [ __ ] april 25th oh
man you missed it i assume it went well
but was empty because i didn't plug it
here i heard you killed and didn't get
slapped exactly perfect that's all that
matters that's all we wanted you're
doing the tonight show right after this
i am yes showbiz showbiz i got things to
push i got the bubble on netflix april
1st i've got
the book sticker in the head i have a
george carlin documentary coming out the
end of may can't wait i have three
things to peddle you're a machine man i
mean the shandling dock was incredible
thank you oh yeah this one is
crazy i mean
i was scared to make it because i only
met george carlin once i interviewed him
when i was like 20 years old for
canadian television and it was the only
interview i couldn't find ah literally
this whole career the only thing i
looked for that did not exist was me as
a young idiot talking to him for
canadian tv i wonder if you go up there
they have it
i begged it i called all those people
you know what did exist
paul reiser's sister interviewed him
for
her college radio station in like
1971.
and paul reiser had the tape wow and she
did a really good interview it was right
when he grew the beard and uh grew the
hair you know he went from being a
little corny yeah to edgier and the
story uh that they tell about it is
they do it at their apartment in new
york city
i know maybe they lived on long island
but anyway near the city he comes over
she does the interview and afterwards he
says i gotta go i i'm gonna i'm gonna go
uh buy a camera and their dad says i'll
take you i know a guy on the lower east
side you get he'll give you a good price
on a camera and they go with him and
george carlin buys a camera they're all
like in the car together wow and then
she sees him a year later i guess she
gets another interview with him somehow
and she asked him about the camera and
he said uh yeah no i didn't want to get
a camera i was actually trying to go
uptown to buy cocaine
damn wow
i met him what was sorry no no i met him
once and he couldn't have been more
carlony and i loved it he did a book
signing at borders i skipped work to go
there in wall street and i waited in
line and i was so excited i had like
three books when jesus bring the pork
chop brain droppings all that [ __ ] i'm a
huge fan napalm and silly people they
probably silly buddy that was the other
one and i could hear people in line
going i loved you and jersey girl i
loved you in uh dog but i'm like ah what
are you bill and ted that was great i'm
like what are you doing rain droppings
yes
back in town uh complaints and
grievances you know
stuff football baseball the whole thing
and i went up to and i just unloaded on
him and he goes what do you do he's like
stop me and i go i'm a comedian he goes
you sound like a comedian i go thank you
and he goes you got a real talent for
jacking around
i don't know what that means but i'll
take it oh he signed the book we got a
photo i think he was nice to comedians
yes because i kept hearing from people
they would meet him once and he would
say give me your number i'll check in on
you and sometimes like randomly like
eight months later he would go how's it
going and he would just be nice to
people shandling has that story about
how he met him you know he he went down
there and he said it's not great but
there's something funny on every page
yeah he gave it he wanted to write jokes
for him and one of the bits he wrote for
him was a commercial for legalized
marijuana
back in like the early 70s yeah and time
has really changed it's really crazy oh
yeah my mom used to hide my weed now she
she just took weed for a doctor gave her
weed for her yeah there you go she used
to hide my i told him i do think there's
a little ironic and she was like no it's
i've headaches yeah i'm still
i always say weed and cigarettes change
change places yeah my mom used to smoke
then she now she has weed yeah
it's you know it's weird now as a parent
because it's legal
and so you have kids right and you're
just like you can't do that and they're
like no it's a fully lawful thing to do
it's their beer right right at this
point and so and also on some level and
you can't really say it out loud
would you be happier if they were
smoking weed than drinking of course so
are we steering our kids to the weed
we are weed seems more peaceful but it
also seems like drinking with family is
easier because drinking is suppressing
stuff weeds you're like does my mom not
like me really you know you're having
bad thoughts yeah i don't know my mom
just told me she didn't like it
but yeah
um
yeah you know i i there's so much i want
to ask you about like obviously the book
is i i i'm only like i've only got a few
of the interviews but they're they're
awesome but i i mean there's i think you
were talking to uh cameron crowe about
james l brooks being a mentor wow james
brooks is i feel like one of the most
legendary yes taxi
sim
yeah i mean the mary tyler moore show
and then he was producing all the
spin-offs like rhoda and and lou grant
and broadcast news and there's things
that people don't remember as well he
wrote a funny movie with that started
burt reynolds and candace bergen that
was really really funny and i worked for
him on the critic
we do recommendations every week on this
the critic has been a recommendation
because they're all on youtube yeah
it's one of the best shows yeah because
it was the guys from the simpsons it was
mike reese and al jean yeah who created
it and it was john levitz is like a
roger ebert guy right and had tons of
parodies in it and it looked like a big
new yorker drawing yes and that was
really my first
job on the show with a story i i used to
work half the week on the critic and
half the week at larry sanders and then
james brooks would come in and he was
like so brilliant and we would we would
have to pitch him our ideas for stories
and you'd wait because he was a busy guy
to get him to make an appointment to sit
with the writers to hear everyone's
ideas for stories and i always remember
him
stumbling in the room
and we're about to pitch our ideas and
we all have a little pads with our ideas
and he's like you know i think
what a good story could be he pitches us
through ideas gets up walks out of the
room
like didn't remember why he was there
all his ideas were better than our ideas
and then just do you remember
i do remember one thing that he said to
me on my pitch which i do think shows
you what a genius he is my pitch was
that that it was uh
the guy's name was jay
the the critic that his parents are are
really rich in in the show and and i
think it's supposed to be like he's
adopted and they're very waspy
catherine hepburn yeah
yeah and that and and the dad is kind of
losing it right a little bit like a
non-sequitur
guy and so they get in a plane crash
is the idea and they're on a
now they're on a deserted island the
parents
and my idea was that jay finds out that
they were like
part of the you know what they call that
the illuminati or something like they
run the world they're so rich and now he
is on the committee to run the world
because the parents died right but then
you cut to the
to the uh the place where the desert
island where they are and i didn't
really have an idea for that and james
brooks said
what if on the island
you know their marriage is really stale
and it's been still for a long time but
on this island they kind of rebuild
their world with like trees and twigs
and they remake it on the island they
look kind of sexy like they're kind of
cut up a little bit and they're dirty
and they fall in love and it gets hot
again yeah
that's how great he is like that's what
he took from my dumb idea right right he
went blue lagoon on it he did yeah
damn he just goes to like character
going deep yeah
stories about love and connection and
all the ways we're neurotic and and
i think that's why he's such a great
producer because he produced big he
produced bottle rocket he produced jerry
maguire he produced
the first cameron crow movie that he
directed say anything oh wow you know so
he's also the best guy to
read your stuff and tell you how to make
it better yeah that must be terrifying
because because you know he's that good
at it
you know all his pitches are better than
what you're yeah you do i'm i'm always
intimidated everywhere i go oh there's
david tell there's chris rock whatever
it is i mean i can't imagine going to
work
with these guys that's insane i would be
freaking out it didn't ever because it
was scary it really was scary i used
when i was really young
you're not in a position of power so
you don't really get to choose what
jokes or what stories get done so as an
entry-level writer all you're doing is
vomiting out what if what about this
what about this joke what about this
thing and then they just say yes no yes
no and if you don't mind being rejected
80 90 of the time it's a it's a good job
and then slowly you start getting access
to the conversation about what stories
should we do right
terrifying yeah was who was was james
the most intimidating person you worked
for coming up
i mean he wasn't
intimidating necessarily because he did
something
that i think a lot of good comedians do
is when you would pitch him something
he never said it was bad
so if i pitched a bad story he would
like sit and think and go
what could you do with this
he never gave you that look like you
idiot right you know so even the worst
idea he's like one and he would sit and
he would try to what if it for a while
to see if it led to something else and
that was the main lesson i learned from
him was okay this is like a starting
point for someone else's inspiration
yeah we we write together and we'll do
that too i never go that's you're so
good at that actually
mark and i since we were open micros
would bounce bits and uh and mark we i
have some friends you like you tell a
bit too and they're just like ugh you
know
but mark is always like
what if what if it was i think this is
what you're trying to say he's very
encouraging so well there's usually a
nugget a kernel we can go another way
there's always something well
something's bubbling up right exactly
and i think that that's how i i've tried
to
look at writing which is why am i
thinking about this
like something from my unconscious is
trying to get out i don't know why and
usually whether that's a script or a
joke like why why do i want to talk
about
you know
having babies yeah you know why is that
on my mind i mean
i think someone said like you write the
movie to figure out why you're writing
the movie oh and sometimes you don't
know till you finish it what is it
really about
these relationships like right when i
was a kid
you know my dad got remarried my mom got
remarried i didn't think that much of it
it was always an adjustment you'd be
awkward for a while it's new people in
your life and i worked with pete
davidson on king of staten island for a
few years
and it what is it about it's about
getting comfortable with what's going to
be your stepdad bill byrne right but
while we're doing it i'm not that
conscious of oh i have all these issues
yeah the resistance to like loving the
new person that's trying to figure you
out well so you were you're relating
you're looking at through peach lens
with that yeah interesting but i didn't
think about it maybe that much even
while we were writing it and doing it oh
this is weirdly personal for me
in trying to build those relationships
and and how it takes a little bit
do you think on some level that's what
drew you to work with pete
i mean aside that he's interesting that
he's someone that makes sense to work
with but but do you think when you're
like when you're are you helping him
kind of structure that story that's part
of it is i mean in the beginning we were
talking about just like silly ideas so
him and dave cyrus wrote another idea
for me and it was just a silly idea and
it wasn't really
coming to fruition and then usually we
have a moment where i'll just say
what should we be writing about uh-huh
and then he kept talking about wanting
his mom to date
and that kept coming up as a theme
feeling bad that his mom isn't dating
right yeah and then
it was like well
how honest do you want to get yeah how
deep do you want to go and then slowly
he's like yeah i wouldn't mind writing
about it
because it's sacred you know talking
about losing your dad and and what his
life has been like what his family's
life has been like and then you start
saying
would your family care if you wrote
about this and he's like oh no they'd
love it oh all right how honest can we
get yeah completely and most people will
say well we can say this but we can't
say that and peter's always
we're all in and then i called his mom
and we talked about it and started
writing he's been so
in the public scrutiny since what like
18 yeah that it probably helps being
that open a book because he's just like
you can't hurt me right yeah and i mean
i'm sure you can but you know what i
mean like comedically almost nothing's
off limits in that way well public
scrutiny since
9 11 because he said he they would take
all the kids to yankee games and
football games yeah you know everyone
was trying to make them feel better and
he and he's talked a lot about this
publicly just how uncomfortable it made
him
because
it wasn't a normal form of getting over
chairs yeah hey your dad's gone go watch
jason giambi yeah exactly go to the
white house the president right right
that's not helping yeah of course that's
it's uh
it's interesting because i think about
your work and like you kind of have a
levels where uh like you'll do something
that's a little more silly but then
you'll go kind of like even like
undeclared to freaks and geeks there's
such different tones yes yeah well i
always thought that undeclared like
college is like the gift you get for
surviving how shitty high school is so
it seemed like after this brutal high
school experience that if you did a show
about college it would be
that's the place you go to redefine
yourself right everyone thinks i'm an
idiot here i'm gonna go there no one
knows who i am can i act cool enough to
be accepted as a different kind of
person and then slowly they they figured
out i remember there was an episode
where martin starr played his friend
from back home
who was you know like a nerdy guy
and that's when he felt like he was
going to be outed that's not the cool
person he was trying to pretend that he
was right and that's what i always
thought at college like this is the
moment that i can like put everything
behind me yes and people will think i'm
cool i remember like drinking with all
the football players during the first
week of school and just vomiting
immediately and instantly being a loser
again they don't know i'm a dork
after college you're punished with
marriage exactly you know punish high
school fun college the rest of your life
sucks
i'm about to have my 25th wedding
anniversary holy congratulations or it's
a dream
for a quarter century
yeah and now your kids are cooking
they're they're rocking and rolling
they're working iris is in the bubble
iris is in the bubble and she's really
really funny she plays a
tick tock star who's been jammed into
the movie just because she has a lot of
followers and doesn't know how to pass
and she was on love and was really funny
on that and then mod is on euphoria
right now yeah i haven't seen yet
everyone pitching it to me it sounds
terror i don't want to watch kids on
drugs you do you do
i hear it's amazing i'm terrified it's a
great show and it's just they push the
limits it's wild i gotta watch it it's
fun hbo still does make some cool stuff
oh hbo is the best yeah yeah it's uh
it's it's amazing to just watch
yeah her
do it like learn you know she's you
watch i mean i've only gone to the set
twice but just her talking about it the
process of everybody figuring out the
show sam levinson writes and directs
every episode it's a pretty remarkable
feat
and
then you see what they did and you can't
believe how how good it is because like
for me i'm working so hard and at the
end you're like god i hope i didn't
screw this up so you know from a
distance
to observe a very long process and then
he just
really sticks the landing on the whole
thing
i gotta i'm so impressed it's heavy duty
do you do you feel like you set your
kids up for showbiz by putting them in
the movies when they were leon i think
uh you know i've either helped them ruin
their lives because you don't really
know because if i talk about dentistry
their whole
lives maybe they would love the teeth
maybe they'd be an orthodontist maybe
they would be an oral surgeon and so if
you only talk about
jokes and storytelling and you get a
kick out of it and also you have people
around like they're around funny people
yeah and
those people are interesting and you
know we can say it they're more
interesting than a lot of other people
you meet you guys
you know so and so then you'd like the
idea of being around
creative people silly people
and
and then they weren't pushed into it
they just they kind of did it even
though they weren't asking to do it i
was just like why don't you play the
kids in this i don't want to meet other
people's kids
and you get to spend time with your
family right yeah we're gonna hang out
for three months and then like two years
later we would do it again it wasn't
like all the time sure but it was enough
that each time they got better at it and
got more comfortable and now that
they're adults they just
know how to do it right it's almost like
learning a language or something like
this like it's like learning spanish
when you're three and you just know it
exactly or just not being terrified when
you're sitting in a chair and you have
to do a scene and there's like 80 people
watching because you've done it for such
a long time that you've just gotten used
to that space right because so much of
acting i think is about being terrified
like if you get rid of the fear and
relax most people
could do it if you're not self-conscious
i can't do it i've tried and i still
can't act yeah i can't i can't let go
you don't act in anything i mean i'll do
like a little sketch here and there like
a one scene thing
in a movie uh
but
you know i was i was in the disaster
artist as like a yeah as a mean producer
right and they were like yeah i need to
play this jerk producer and i'm like oh
that would be fun and they have me sit
with like a really young
you know beautiful woman and it's all
like kind of like i'm like the creepy
uh producer who's really vicious to
james franco's character and i'm like
yelling at him like no one makes it even
if you're great it's a one in a million
if you're a genius it's a one in a
million that you get to break and make
it you played the tim dillon character
yeah exactly
and then i see the movie i look at the
credits and it says judd apatow as
himself
now what about the synergy raw kombucha
well i've never had it before is it the
strong is it i don't know if you're
supposed to shake it up oh you don't
talk about it
yeah should we get you another one
a bubble well is it uh it's live
something it's probably cheers
but is it tastes good or is it good it's
bad well basically we got drunk with
bert christian for three hours yesterday
we are hurting there you go
yeah burt was literally every round he'd
be like catch up and we're like all
right so that turned into a three it's
usually as i said around a one-hour
episode with berta turned into three
yeah uh you went all the way with him oh
yeah
then i'm on the tonight show today so
you got you gotta go good person this is
tea time yeah this is great i wrote
how i think of this is
when we did the ben stiller show many
many moons ago
andy dick at the time was very sober and
very healthy and he drank this all the
time really he was always drinking this
but at the time it didn't look like this
like this looks like a gatorade or
something back then it looked like there
was
like octopus in it and stuff like there
was something i don't know how they
presented it but they were living
stringy things it was flip water and so
i still think of it as disgusting like
that but i'm gonna try it's pretty good
they cleaned it up a little bit they got
their activities they strained it
do you get nervous to do a late night
spot appearance
um i i get a little bit nervous this may
be the least prepared i've ever been and
sometimes i think well is that good to
just
because he's nice and
you know he's funny and maybe i just
need to be interesting and something
will happen and then other times i
prepare like every word like it's it's
bits i really run it like like a late
night set for panel sometimes right yeah
like i've done the stories and i didn't
do that this time but this is like a
very loose
version of it so yeah this is the can i
be interesting or you know sometimes i
think you know judd you do stand up
comedy but you're also a director and a
director does not have to be funny he
can be interesting
so maybe i'm interesting i do uh one of
those appearances well if you go in
interesting anything you say that's
slightly humorous is now a win exactly
you know it's like when a rock star yeah
does patter between songs he's murdering
right you know because you just don't
expect it yeah and you're like i
wouldn't even
put that in my act anywhere
he kills did you see a ted talk with
like a little quick
joke in there and the guy gets a huge
laugh yeah
or a funeral is a big one too you did
you did a stand-up set though on fallon
once i did i did it was uh
they asked me to do a stand-up set and
this is how you know they thought i was
just a curiosity and it wasn't like an
earned stand-up set and no one on the
show asked to see it beforehand
but is that flattering or is that no i
think that's because you're a star yeah
i don't think that's because you're not
that you didn't earn it you killed a set
i still remember the cosby joke yeah
that's a great joke well the thing was i
ran it at the seller a bunch the set and
i wasn't going to do the cosby bit and
the cosby bit was just all about cosby
hiding the newspaper so camille wouldn't
fear that he's in trouble right and um
and then it was like doing a cosby
routine about
hiding the paper and every day i would
go to the driveway night get up early
and hide the paper right and uh and i
wasn't gonna do it because i thought oh
this is a little too much
uh to do and then i forgot who it was
but i got off stage and somebody could
have been you just went well you gotta
do the cosby thing it might have been me
obviously
it might have been literally it could
have been you and i was like really like
yeah i think that's like the best thing
and then
all right i mean then that became like
half the set right right sam also told
rock to do the jaded job
we don't know every joke's an experiment
that's true you don't you don't know
what jokes are going to work that's what
makes it so exciting failure can happen
at any moment i think for the now on the
stage you'll have to be four feet tall
because if you have to jump up to get on
the stage i think it'll it looks foolish
yes
you don't want to squirm to get the slap
off right doesn't look good but the fact
he could just
sashay up there was there any step
nothing
that was the issue
even if he's in the fifth row he's got a
shimmy down that changes things too
yeah it's all set design is always the
problem
yes exactly
build that wall around the stage i want
to ask about because freaks and geeks do
you get asked about that a lot i do and
you know the great thing about it that's
nice is when it got cancelled
you really think no one may ever see it
again you don't know that it's going to
come out back then like vhs or dvd like
that's not guaranteed that that happens
right and so
your nightmare is it's going to go down
some digital black hole
and never be able to be seen again
because someone has to like pay to get
it out there so the fact that it's on
hulu now and i really think more people
watch it every year than ever watched it
whoa when it was on and so it's almost
like a new project which i get a kick
out of and it was shot to look like
something made in 1980 right so
something about the style of it doesn't
age because it's meant to be
a little old-looking
and and also there's all this music in
it
you know back then nobody put classic
rock in tv shows the only show that did
it a teeny bit was the wonder years but
if you watch tv if you're watching like
lou grant or something or nypd blue they
didn't put like the grateful dead in it
there was no music in shows
dawson's creek had a little pop music
uh here and there and we said what if we
pack this thing like a scorsese movie
right would that cost a lot of money
well back then it really didn't cost
that much we budgeted for it but say it
cost like 100 an episode to fill it with
with songs by
you know ted nugent and sticks and and
billy joel and people like that and
everybody said yes
and we put van halen in the show if you
tried to do that right now
it would just cost you millions of
dollars perhaps everyone has asked for
an enormous amount of money
to do that and now it's in all the shows
but back then you know we would call the
grateful dead and they'd be like oh no
one's ever asked for a song before wow
for anything
billy joel wasn't in any movies or tv
shows sticks was never in yeah in
anything so for us it was like oh it's
all open yeah it's open season it's a
little generic now but back then it was
so fun interesting i never thought about
the music
that scene where martin starr is eating
the yeah what's he eating he's like
meatloaf or an eclair or something and
his mouth is he's got milk and he's
eating grilled cheese and entenmann's
cake yes which is what i did every day
as a kid i would sit and watch dinoshore
and eat grilled cheese and
entertainment's cake and watch the
comics that hit home that was that was
my answer
in that episode and i put channeling in
there as a as a respect to shandling and
and that and i put the who the song i'm
one under it because it's all about like
feeling like an outcast man you were
just jerking it this was an appetite
moment yeah yeah it was it was uh
and there was another sequence in that
show
where
uh bill
gets up
and he uh
he's
he sees his mom's
new boyfriend which is his gym teacher
and then he takes a mug that's like
world's best dad and we had this great
bad finger song
um
and we couldn't get it because they
were like in whatever legal problems
with all their stuff and it was like the
saddest thing that we couldn't get this
song was it was like that sequence it
was so great with that song right and
then we couldn't get that song and all
the guys in that band were always broke
and their lives were falling apart
because something got [ __ ] up in all
their contracts and they couldn't sell
their music yeah do you feel like it's
bittersweet now because when i started
comedy there wasn't much
obviously there were no podcasts back
then like in 2006
you know i had the cds on comedy
remember woody allen had one seinfeld
had one a couple other guys now there's
like eight zillion comedic avenues and
internet shows and everything
is it good or bad that there's this much
access to comedy or was comedy better
when it was this kind of niche
underground
thing
i don't know because you know when i was
a kid i mean like the book where
we have here sitter in the head yes
where i interview all the comics when i
did it as a as a kid i did it because
there were no interviews so other than
like those weird cds yeah there was
almost nothing so as a as a young person
who wanted to know like how do you do it
there was nowhere to check so you were
like actually interviewing seinfeld
because you're like i want to know how
to do this exactly and i heard those old
ones and literally it's like 1984. yes
and so it's before seinfeld but people
still thought he was the greatest comic
wow and you said in the book it says
something about how he was kind of icy
to you but then he saw you cared and
that kind of softened him that's the key
well i showed him at the door and i
think he didn't realize it was a child
and so you always have to decide am i
actually even going to do this right
right right and then i'm so earnest as a
kid and i love him so much yeah that at
some point he got like very kind and i
said how do you write a joke and then he
started walking me through
a premise he was working on the premise
he was working on was uh
how do you catch a bullet between your
teeth yes that he saw that and that's
incredible and he's like well how do you
how do you learn how to do that i mean
do you start with a grape
he goes
and this is the thing that made me laugh
and i learned a lot from him saying this
he said then i started thinking i don't
remember his name
and the guy's got to think what the hell
do i need to do
to get you to remember my name and he
just started showing me how his mind
works right and and you know i did that
with 50 different people and you don't
even realize what you're picking up yeah
but the main thing i picked up from it
was they worked their asses off and it
took like seven to ten years to figure
it out exactly and so as a 16 year old
to program in your brain i have a goal
and if i start now at like 17 i won't be
good till i'm 25. yep and i'm okay with
that that was life-changing because i
think now everyone thinks they're
supposed to be amazing in the first
three months well they could tick-tock
it and be you know the people who are
selling tickets on the road through
tick-tock you know and they don't have
an act right
which sounds horrible to me i mean it's
great that you're making a living but
it's also like the people that are
paying money to see you are going to
hate the show yeah totally yeah and now
uh
yeah everything everyone feels like they
should be a star instantly yes and i
really thought oh seven years and i also
thought okay which isn't crazy by the
way that's like think about like any job
to be a doctor to be a lawyer it's like
college and then law school right i mean
that seven years sounds reasonable and
in my head what i thought was okay i'm
17.
24. i'm eddie murphy
that's not bad
we might be drunk is brought to you by
manscaped it's time for spring cleaning
better start with that winter bush save
big by going to manscape.com for 20 off
and freeze shipping with the code drunk
get your day started by trimming those
wayward hairs with the waterproof
lawnmower 4.0 clear your holes and smell
the spring air with the weed whacker
and also clean up with their crop
preserver and crop
reviver
finish up your grooming routine with the
plow 2.0 the perfect razor for the
finest shave on your face because if
you're using your lawnmower 4.0 in your
balls in your face you're doing it yes
you can't do the same you can't do the
balls and the face that's pretty gross
you know manscaped has partnered with
the testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to testicular cancer
men's health and early cancer detection
manscape
a manscaped is committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and giving
support for fighters survivors and
families in spy impacted by testicular
cancer as part of the we save balls
initiative
mark tell them how to do it here here
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code drunk at manscaped.com that's 20
off plus free shipping at manscape.com
and use promo code drunk it's time to
throw out your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life support the show and
get 20 off or off and free shipping with
drunk at
manscape.com get on it folks and save
those balls
hey
we might be drunk is brought to you by
lucy you're a responsible consumer and
you want a responsible way to consume
your nicotine don't you
well if you're looking for nicotine gum
lozenges or pouches to use nicotine to
relax focus or just unwind after a long
day there's only one stop you should
make lucy
i like this stuff the gum tastes great i
prefer the lozenges because you just
throw them in you're not smacking around
town with the chewing so uh get on it
plus you know
it just tastes good then it gives you a
little jolt that yeah oh yeah it gives
you a kick if if i'm hungover
i pop one of those in and i'm like
pretty good it's the least healthy
endorsement of all time also if you're
going to the casino hitting the slots
just chew the gum and you get the same
the nicotine without having to kill your
lungs
so you've been looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch a
nicotine product that can actually make
you feel good and feel good about doing
it tell them how fatty if you enjoy
using nicotine you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy.co
that's lucy.co promo code drunk at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk we might be drunk is brought
to you by disc plate
displayed is a one of a kind metal
poster designed to capture your unique
passions they have millions of cool
designs available featuring gaming
movies comics anime with officially
licensed designed
designs from bethesda star wars netflix
and many more
it only takes 20 seconds to set up with
no power tools no damages no
frustrations and once you mount one you
can switch out a new one in a flash
wow
look at that folks holy hell
look at that metal is it upside down
it's upside down oops sorry everybody
there you go the triple lindy yes
uh and with everyone that you buy this
plate will plant a tree tell them how
samuel click the link in our description
to see some of our favorite disc plates
and get our special discount 20 to 23
off up to two displays or 34 off three
or more disc plates which will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit diskplate.com it's
an amazing deal and only available for a
limited time and i mean that's a classic
poster classic i love it it's light it's
fresh it feels good look i think it
comes with some minis too look at that a
magnet there
super cool thank you displate get on it
get your own thing
did you uh so seinfeld when did you
mention when you were a successful
writer was there a point where you were
like do you remember did you ever bring
it up to him i think i probably waited
almost like deep into my 30s
to mention i think at some point
when i started having some success with
like the four-year-old virgin
i mentioned it and i would let people
print a picture of me
at 16 with seinfeld
and then he's like oh my god and i don't
remember if he really remembered it
right you know
when it happened the funny thing is i
interviewed him again the next year and
he said why would i do it again
and i said to him as a kid i'm like well
you did the tonight show twice
and he did it he did like another
another hour with me and you know that
kindness like when you go oh this is
this is how you're supposed to behave
towards people
because because there were people who
weren't nice yes and and then there'd be
people would be so nice they would take
out their phone book and go hey do you
want to interview rodney dangerfield do
you want to interview so did you
interview rodney i never got rodney but
like people would just give me his home
phone number stuff and alan zweibel from
saturday yeah
would give me people's phone numbers
and
i think that was maybe the most
important part of the whole process was
oh this this is what kindness says right
this is what mentorship i've noticed the
funny guys tend to be kind a lot of the
uh the dicks are usually hacks yeah the
better comics are nicer for the most
exactly they're more self-aware yeah so
you'd seinfeld was who were the other
big ones you talked to when you were
young that had a big impression
well there was there were people like
harold ramis whoo
that's right he was in prep for vacation
wow wow
and i remember you started talking about
writing jokes for writing dangerfield
and getting 50 bucks a joke and
i never knew that like
someone would write the jokes for people
yeah so that was a big thing so at 16
i'm like oh which is not really a thing
anymore i mean i think that that's like
an old-school show business yeah i mean
if you have a tv show obviously or
you're doing the oscars or something
yeah yeah and there and there are people
that yeah there are some people who do a
little bit of that if they're like
really cranking out stuff but it
definitely programmed in my brain oh i
can do stand up and sell jokes to pay my
rent so when i first started out i wrote
jokes for
george wallace and taylor negron and wow
i did a session for jeff dunham's old
man puppet
wow with my friend joel madison wow and
i thought that's a cool thing to do no
one else was doing it there weren't any
other comics who were willing to spend
their
comedy bandwidth because they're helping
somebody help the jokes too dear yeah
they didn't want to do it you know but i
did it and you know who i did it with
norm no way me and norm and and i
believe john reedy got hired to write
jokes for roseanne wow wow i remember me
and norm
uh i forgot to read you was there just
driving to roseanne's house
sitting at her breakfast table and she
takes out a big stack of legal pads
with all of her ideas yeah and and then
we would like try to help her turn him
into jokes very quickly he got hired on
roseanne and then he got snl like a few
months later like his thing blew up
really fast could you tell when hanging
out because he's like one of my heroes
could you tell hanging out like oh this
guy's amazing this guy's brilliant
the second i saw him i was living with
sandler we were both you know struggling
him less than me because he would be on
remote control on mtv and he had vj
every once in a while but he you know so
that was like a thing that'd be like mtv
tours sure that adam would go on but
adam had a lot of energy like to succeed
and i came at it really as a fan so i
saw a norm on something and i had the
tape of it and i'm like sandler you got
to see this [ __ ] nor macdonald wow
this is like the funniest guy ever and i
would do this to adam all the time
would i like somebody
and he would always say like i'll give a
[ __ ] if he's funny i'm trying to be
funny right right i'm trying to make it
i don't care if he makes it yeah and
then the funny part is he became norma's
biggest right supporter and then
something in all the movies and billy
madison and suddenly like norms around
all the time and i'm like i told you
it's norm nor it's the one yeah comics
also i think we have like the arrogance
that we kind of want to discover the
comic ourselves
when someone pushes a comic on you it's
almost like being like being pushed to
go on a date with someone you're like
[ __ ] off i'll meet someone you know
well i just had also had that nerdy fan
thing and sandler's thing back then he
loved rodney
and he worked at danger fields and
all right that club's no longer here i
know and that i remember doing a couple
of spots there back in the day and
and that was his guy he just he loved
ronnie and then rodney was in little
nicky that's great right
and then once we all flew to vegas
to see rodney perform when rodney was
like 80 something wow and sandler like
charters a jet and we all fly out there
and it's like this really like funny
group it's like me sandler schneider
covert
carl weathers
and quentin tarantino that was the group
and we're all just fly to vegas to see
rodney that's the only reason we're
going just to pay respects wow to
writing
natural born killers i'm thinking
oh yeah and
and then he was great in his 80s he was
great and then someone started heckling
him
and he just tore the guy apart and he
woke up too to another level and he
loved
destroying the guy and then we hung out
after with him and and he was just such
a such a character man there's a
oh sorry there's a great clip of rodney
it's in the is in the box set uh which i
mean i don't know if we get a box
anymore it must be on youtube somewhere
but he's in his 80s doing stand-up in
vegas
and it's not a good crowd and it gets to
a point where he's not doing great and
it's kind of sad and then he it's
another thing where he wakes up and he
just rattles joke jokes
and at the end he gets a big applause
break and he just goes i know a lot of
[ __ ] jokes
like the funniest thing he's like yeah i
still got it i love it well i love like
these old records like like you have
this one here i don't get no respect but
rodney's thing was
and i don't know if it was cocaine
induced or what he used to talk slow
like
he used to be a storyteller and he was
funny and and he would look like this
and he would say you ever got into the
mechanic
and so you had a whole different
effect to him and it was really funny
and dark and weird and then suddenly it
got super fast and crazy and i remember
seeing him when i was like 13 or 14 at
westbury music fair
and it really was the case that
certain jokes would kill so hard that
you would miss the next two wow like it
was just pandemonium and maybe he was on
coke and just moving way too fast
but he murdered like i'd never seen yeah
tonight's show stuff it's hauls like
eight million nine million views on
youtube still holds up still hilarious
and long like he used to do like eight
minute sets or ten minute sets he would
sit down with johnny do another ten
minutes i know on the couch so many i
try to avoid if i do a late night i try
to do it i'm like can i do 345 right how
can i get not burn everything yeah
but back then that was the spot to burn
it you're right yeah that was like a
special back then i guess exactly
everybody in america was watching that
thing but norm would always say he would
rehearse and practice like crazy for
those panel sessions you think it's he's
like a he almost looks high he's off the
cuff he's ripping he's talking about
moths for eight minutes that was all
prepared yeah
i mean
it's really fun to go down the
the norm worm
on because there's a lot of stuff yes if
you want to just look for like
norm on a morning radio show 16 years
ago
talking for an hour and 10 minutes yeah
and being hilarious and crazy there's so
much of it there's one
maybe in the last year of his life where
he
i think it's hawaii
and it gets really like intense and he's
just talking about life and
and he gets he's talking about like
religion and masturbation and they can't
tell if he's goofing on them yeah or not
and i'm not even quite sure because i
think sometimes people they think you're
joking and then your thing is i'm going
to tell them the complete truth yes
about everything and you're going to
think i'm goofing but i am not goofy yes
exactly like andy kaufman was on this
show called like the tom cottle show
he's one of the first
therapists on tv who would like do
therapy with a real person or a
celebrity on tv
and there's a thing of it on on youtube
it's like 20 minutes and you could tell
andy calvin has decided he's going to
drop all of his
character and tell the truth to this guy
on tv and that's the joke
and it's like you can't even believe
you're watching also norm's cadence is
so funny it's hard to picture it's just
it's almost like the curse of rodney
like picture rodney trying to be serious
it's still kind of funny totally the
darkest character ever in natural born
killers and and it's like a laugh track
you're right right there's a norm on the
radio somewhere and he's making fun of
teachers and a teacher calls in and
she's like you don't know how hard it is
and he's like what you're just the
tallest person in the room
all these things and he's like you just
have to be smarter than the fifth grader
you're teaching or whatever and he's
just killing this woman with just facts
and it's all gold and then he has a big
bit about it later in his act but i
wonder if he came off that phone call
but he's just dropping gems and they're
all blown away and he was close to
shooting a special ah at the end of his
life so i always wondered did you know
he was sick or not no i didn't nobody
knew nine years yeah were you still
close with him i mean i don't know i
don't think i was ever like close to
norm i just knew him a little bit for a
really long
time i had done a
largo show with him
a few years before he died and
you know he came in and he was so sharp
and he was so funny backstage and so
nice and then someone gives him a hit on
a joint and then he's a
norm like the whole it was kind of sad
because you could just tell
he could have just crushed it if he
stayed sober right and there's like one
hit he just lost like
half of it yeah and i was mad at my
friend like why are you giving a joint
to norm and then he went on stage and he
has like a decent set
i remember he was doing that stuff about
oj
you know but oh but the irony remember
that bit yeah yeah he got caught for the
shirts yeah not you know he went to jail
for stealing shirts or whatever not the
murderer yeah blah blah blah and at the
end of his set he looks at the crowd
and he's like kind of something like
very emotional and he says uh you know
i'm uh
over here like it's it's so nice you
people are so nice to me
and uh and i walk over there and make
points of the wings
and and it's over and then
it ends and then i'm just over there
alone but if i just stay out here you
know like really feels good like to be
here with you but i have to
i have to go
and then he literally starts crying
on stage and he just takes this long
pause he goes i don't know what to say
and then he just goes
i love you and then he walked off wow
thanks
and now looking back knowing that he was
sick you know you wonder what he was
thinking about and what all those
moments were about and all the routines
because
there's interviews where he talks about
really looking up to um this actor was
his name richard farnsworth the guy who
was in that movie where the guy rides
the lawn mower
across the stage straight
yeah what else is he's in a ton of isn't
he a misery too yeah i mean he was i
think he was a stunt man who became an
actor um pull him up maybe david lynch
uh directed that movie
uh
or gus van zandt i think david lynch but
he was talking about how much he admired
him because he never told anyone he was
sick
and he talked about it for about 10
minutes like how that's the best thing
you could do right does not bother your
family exactly and so he talked about it
but as if it was somebody else yeah he
had that whole i saw i heard him on a
chris hardwick's podcast years ago and
he's like all these comics now they have
these one-man shows about having an
illness and he's like that's not brave
everybody calls him brave he's like no
it's brave to hold it in and not bother
everybody with it oh you got cancer oh
everybody gets cancer you know that's
not a big deal i mean it's a big deal
but it's not you're not special well he
it reminds me of siskel and ebert
because
siskel didn't tell anybody right he told
nobody that he was sick
and
roger ebert i guess was really upset
that he never shared it with him and
then by the time he found out he was
very close to dying and then when roger
ebert got sick he he shared the whole
experience
with the world because he thought that
that's what you do but you know that's a
yeah a private decision yeah exactly
it's it's that person's choice i i don't
judge either way but uh yeah
my body my choice what was the joke that
norm had about uh beating cancer oh oh
yeah isn't this something about like how
it the cancer dies too so it's a draw or
something right right you're battling
with cancer it's like i think he lost
you know it's not really a battle it's a
losing fight i can't remember but it was
great then his dad died and he's like
your dad's in a better place he's on the
floor that was a great bit he's like
we're scared of korea i'm scared of my
heart you know my heart could kill me
from inside i mean brilliant stuff it's
so simple you know like
uh world war ii they attacked the world
you know
it's incredible
gold who do you think you are mars yeah
that was a great tag do you you were you
toured with jim carrey in the 80s right
i did i did yeah he uh
you know he was an impressionist and he
just
didn't want to do impressions anymore he
just decided that he didn't want to
become rich little and
and you know he was playing vegas he
would open up for rodney rodney was one
of his big supporters when he was like
19. wow and then
he stopped for a while he did a couple
of movies none of them did
well uh but just being in movies back
then was probably big it was big like if
you got your shot like he was in this
movie once a bit and it was like a
vampire movie
and uh i used to come on comedy central
like twice a week was it like lauren
hutton in him or something and then
it bombed he had a tv show
about like a cartoonist
the duck factory and that bomb so all
these like big breaks weren't working
and then he didn't know what to do and i
guess a manager said stop doing stand up
and just focus on your acting
and then i think it was like peggy sue
got married and he was trying to build
that career and then out of the bully
just fired the managers and went i
shouldn't be doing stand-up that's
totally wrong
and he decided to go back do no
impressions and he went on stage every
night
and did his act completely improvised
like every night
he would just do a completely different
set
with no
forethought work or just riffing
i mean riffing yeah not crowd work not
where you're from just going in your own
head wow into your own madness
terrifying it wasn't pretty i heard i
was on the comedy story documentary he
talked about he said at one point he got
in the piano got out of the piano just
trying anything he could do to get a
laugh he would like lay in it like
against the back wall like the brick
wall and he would just see how much he
could get in the crack and i remember he
had a bit that he would like take off
his shoe when he was bombing and he
would pretend to call his wife
and he would just go like hi honey no
it's going great
they love me
oh yeah we're not gonna have to worry
about uh making ends meet anymore
and then he would start killing like for
like six seven minutes he would kill and
then it would fall off again yeah but
after a couple of months
he started building something and
almost everything you see in movies like
ace ventura and the mask he came up with
on stage at that time all the
catchphrases let me show you something
and alrighty then and yeah all those
things were it's fire marshall bill and
all things he did
just to that's where he really took
right and and living color he didn't
live in color yeah and then ace ventura
yeah yeah i saw that in the theater with
my mom she's like i don't get it i was
like this is the funniest thing i've
ever seen oh same here i remember my
grandparents took me to dumb and dumber
and they were just like old jews they
were so mad
my grandma was like that was the worst
they want to see apollo 13 or something
like that i talked him in a dumb and
dumber yeah
good they're like i like bob oh
well i remember my grandparents would
see buddy hack and they'd be like he's
so dirty in my head i'm like oh you
you're dirty that's what yeah but uh
you could be dirty i mean gilbert filthy
well what about uh
in the book letterman's talking about
how he hates impressions i feel like
that was probably the vibe that that
people like rodney told him he was
better than that right
well i think that uh
jim thought
that i would assume that he thought that
people thought he was corny in some way
and the thing that i think he was wrong
about was he wasn't doing normal
impressions right so jim thought oh i'm
turning into fred traveling or somebody
but what he was doing was like really
innovative and demented because he would
just for a lot of it just do people's
faces like he would just do clint
eastwood and like he could change his
face and then he would do james dean and
he i remember used to do bruce dern wow
another like crazy could just become
bruce dern's face but i think in the
beginning maybe he was like also like
singing a song as sammy davis jr yeah he
you had a whole ungolden pond like henry
fonda [ __ ] yeah but then it turned into
like post nuclear elvis presley
impressions that's great with jimmy
stewart yeah the apocalypse yeah stuff
like that and so i would go out with him
and in the beginning i remember we went
to laying a punch line
and we're still there different location
but yeah we did a week in sandy springs
and
he didn't get booked back
like oh wow the response was no you
can't come back yeah
and he was still great like anyone
should go wait a second that was amazing
even if it was a little hit and miss at
the time and then it just started
murdering and he did a special and
mm-hmm and he he had the killer set yeah
you got to get over that hump
you got to find it it's so weird to
picture just jim carrey bombing i mean
it's
you know because he doesn't do stand-up
anymore but then it's i feel like a lot
of people don't even know he did stand
up
it was also like not normal jokes it was
right
uh
it was surrealistic right in some way
and people had never really seen it and
he wasn't famous
so
some nights people would he would just
get the room and then other nights it
would be always hit and miss he never
like
when he had the act would bomb but just
there were certain nights where it was
pandemonium and then suddenly he's
ventura hit
and then he was he was jim and then he
didn't want to do it anymore and it's
funny as three weeks ago i did a largo
and i i heard that jim had been on stage
at the bob saget memorial and people
said he was really funny and he hadn't
really been on stage at the store in
like 20 years and so i said
you know i got a largo coming up you
want to just come on stage and just chat
like you don't have to do a set we'll
just like i'll just ask you questions
and he did he came and then i just asked
some questions i knew the answers to
like you know you're just like please
don't cry at the end of your set here
yeah
i want this to go well and then i asked
him about kennison and he had an amazing
kennison story and an amazing
dangerfield story and then you know
the funniest person in the world like
right away you go there it is if he ever
wanted to do it yeah you know he could
do it very quickly and i hope he does i
think there is a chance
at some point he might consider it i
think so too because it's so fun yeah
and you get bored and movies don't
really scratch that itch but but i will
say eddie murphy always hints at coming
back
and i think it's a bad idea i think he's
too much of i mean he can do whatever he
wants but he's a legend we have him up
here in our minds
and to only get good you have to get
good you have to bomb so seeing eddie
murphy bomb i think is too much for
people well it might be a news story
because he's that famous so if he's a
bad set it could be a new and that's the
tough thing when you're that famous
that's why it's hard when you're already
famous to be a killer stand up it's just
hard you got to work your way up i mean
i can use better for doing so many
seller sets because it's like there's no
way around it a lot of people just
wouldn't put in the work i mean i think
that you just have to go i don't care if
you write about my
bad sets i mean the perfect example like
for eddie murphy is mullany
right so fellaini decides to come back
and do stand-up after everything he's
been through yep and he goes and he does
like the the wine uh what's the name
citywide yeah and
people write articles about it and they
they're quoting the set and which is so
messed up
i don't think it's cool to quote a
comedian's material if it's a work in
progress well day one
back yeah but
melanie's tough he didn't care he just
said i'm just going to keep going and so
they did write those articles like they
would write the eddie murphy articles
and then but the eddie murphy eddie
morrison's done stand up in like 35
years has he i mean that that's the
difference mullany's been he's pretty
funny though i don't know how bad the
sets would be i think that eddie murphy
has so much charisma he probably could
he you know he'd have some bumpy rides
but not that bumpy that's true but
ultimately people get bored of those
articles and you go yeah okay you you've
written a lot of what i'm saying people
get bored of it and then at some point
after whatever six months eddie murphy
has the monster set but you have to want
to do it because you got to want to do
it it's a crazy amount of work and you
got to get in the car and you got like
exactly so funny
like maybe he'll just do like a road
club to work and you're like yeah eddie
murphy at the punch line and put glasses
on to read his notes
right like yeah everybody so
you have to really want 80 million
dollars exactly he probably has 80. yeah
yeah but i saw the seinfeld gotham and
he it was like you know when the
pandemic was slowing down and he was
like doing his first sets in a long time
and you can see he's so excited yeah to
get up there and i think you either have
that or you don't right you either love
it and you cannot stop that person like
kevin nealon is so righteously funny
he's funny and he loves it i did a show
with him recently he he killed harder
than i've ever seen him kill wow but
some people just they just start
enjoying
other things which is fine i mean if you
don't have that fire and you focus he
has like 10 kids i mean there's a lot of
reasons why it may not be worth his time
sure but you got to do it one set at a
time it's like getting buff know you go
i wanna be buff you gotta do the reps
you gotta go to the gym and i think a
lot of people don't wanna go to the gym
yeah they wanna be buff
yeah
what uh
when you were doing that when you were
working on it were you doing clubs on
the road or were you doing theaters or
what were you just working on in the
city or in l.a or when i was working on
the the set for my special you know i
i went to like the dc improv and i went
to comedy on states and oh wow um
yeah i tried to go to places with the
good crowds and and but but most of it
at the cellar a lot of largo shows yep
and
and i tried to have some momentum into
into shooting it like you know like on
the road straight into
the shoot and i was happy with the you
know with the set i also you know in my
head i literally thought i'd love to do
a special before i'm completely bald
and i'd like to like while i look okay
i'd like to kind of get it all down at
this stage of life but also my kids were
a certain age and i feel like they both
are out of the house now and it captured
a period of what life was and parenting
and
you know what was happening so i'm i'm
glad that i got it done yeah that
special's called judd apatow thinning
and you also produced two
how many specials do you produce i know
you did gary and chris gethard and ricky
and ricky okay i was gonna say is there
a theme of like depression or like
darkness that you're looking for but
ricky is not he's not like that really
he's got anxiety stuff anxiety but but
but gary
very specifically was about yeah the
great depression yeah and and that was
an amazing satin killer and put him on
the map i think well i mean we've all
known that he's the greatest forever but
that was a very special set
and it was so funny and so vulnerable
and open and chris gethard's show career
suicide was an amazing
one-man show about all of his struggles
and suicide attempts and wow and it was
a little bit more of a theater piece and
it's it's a really great hbo special um
great storyteller yeah that my friend
michael bonfiglio who i co-directed the
george carlin documentary with he
directed both of those
specials and i'm glad they're out there
because you know both of them said
you know when they were young there's
nothing about depression out there
there's nothing about mental health
stuff to make you feel like
you're not alone in things that are
really hard and so just for that to
exist people watch it and they go oh
there can be light at the end of the
tunnel there's a way through this
and just to know that you're not the
only person suffering with it is a big
deal oh yeah
yeah comedy's come so far like
there's these indian comedy's just new
in india and there's all these guys
that's exactly right he's in the bubble
the movie oh there you go he's a great
guy yeah i just saw him at the cellar
the other night but he'll like rent out
a theater and be like i'm working on my
new hour and that's i don't think
there's a lot of clubs there you know
and comedy's so new they're almost like
in the 80s in india
i think he said he was doing like big
shows like in the woods
like during the pandemic he would just
like set up a thing outside oh yeah i
did those parking lot shows that hit the
the high beams if you really killed you
got the wipers
did you enjoy those or no
i just had to get out of the house had
to get up i never want to do and i never
want to do a roof ever again i made me
so depressed yeah i did one like
corporate thing on zoom yeah it was like
someone's rich person's birthday and
then they had like a lot of big comics
and the whole family's just like sitting
on their couch
and were like doing their act for them
and they were actually nice and like
laughing like it made it not like a
terrible thing and i took it i just gave
the money to charity because i i just
wanted to see what it was
and it was a little too lucrative for
for that kind of thing and uh but big
people it's like really i don't even
know how to say who they were
[Laughter]
and i was like is this what it's become
and then other people do zoom shows
where
there's a hundred people on the zoom and
at first all their mics are kind of on
so if someone was just like talking to
their friend like that you would hear
that also and then they had to figure
out how to deal with that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
i know there's always the old lady whose
face is up against the screen and she's
trying to figure it out and she's like
how do i do this and she's like talking
over your act yeah brutal that was a
tough it was a dark time yeah that was
there and for people just not make money
yeah i mean that's a long run for people
to you know for the for people who you
know if you don't have a lot of money in
the bank and you're gonna have almost
two years where like eighty percent of
it goes away i don't know how a lot of
people survived i mean a lot of a lot of
people didn't and a lot of restaurants
closed and a lot of movie theaters yeah
yeah a lot of stuff that
you know we need entertainment and
restaurants for an economy it's terrible
you know i was hoping more would quit
i feel like we have more than before i
know i get messages from comics
sometimes like uh i just started comedy
two years ago i'm like you started two
years ago you started in march of peak
you started the worst time in history
um yeah that's interesting i mean
you've had such an interesting career
man because you've just done so many
different types of things i mean i just
i just think that like the the tv shows
and the types of movies you make i mean
working on something like the critic and
then making funny people like you can't
have two different types of yeah right
i mean i just think
yeah you always want to go like what
what what else could you do yeah and not
get stuck in the thing even this new
movie the bubble like it's really like
silly it's like a mel brooks movie or i
don't know i mean it's not really that
style i was thinking like christopher
guess and then it kind of veered into a
little the tropic thunder type of thing
but it's
i don't mean this in a bad way but it's
like the dumbest movie i've made like
it's all right it's goofy it's like we
need goofy right now i should distill he
goes it's bonkers
usually like i'm trying to make things
very emotionally grounded and then going
how funny can you be when the characters
are very real
and this i just threw that out the
window for the first time and so that's
scary to go oh i don't have the uh
the grounding that usually makes me feel
comfortable of
how would a normal person behave right
it's scary to have strange
characters who have completely different
uh
ways of communicating that don't
necessarily make sense sure i mean
we haven't had a jerk in so long and we
i missed that kind of stuff that's why i
think that tim robinson show oh yeah hit
so hard because it's so funny silly and
wacky and kind of abstract he's so he
goes so hard that guy it's yeah
it's it's like a level of vulnerability
like people say like this this comic was
so vulnerable like that since i remember
nick vader out we used to do shows like
the creek so you know nick but nick
would go so high energy for like four
people in the crowd and i'd be like this
is balls yes i always loved that nick
just had just balls big act outs for no
payoff that's a terrifying moment for
four people he was hilary i mean he is
hilarious sure that's why people like
say like you know how do you stay
interested because at some point you you
realize like oh i'm like 37 years into
this
wow you know and and if you add like
interviewing people it's like 40 years
of a full obsession and it really is
that it's always terrifying yeah
like every second of it
like my movie comes out on friday the
first yeah it'll by the time this is
that it'll be yeah i don't know if
people are gonna go like oh man thank
you for making me laugh or that is the
stupidest worst movie you've ever made
and that's why you do it yes because
it's just it you cannot hold on to it
and make it
like a stable life
yeah right right you just can't you just
you do not know what people are going to
go for
at any moment and sometimes the thing
that you love
people don't go for it and then 15 years
later
it pops up and you're like what people
like the cable guy now cult classic
right i was going to get to that you
wrote the cable guy i i did yes i not
credited i did like
a lot of writing on the cable guy i was
the producer so as a producer it's very
hard to be credited as a writer like the
rules are that you have to change an
enormous amount
to get the credit which always broke
broke my heart because i was so proud of
the writing on that
uh and then people would laugh at me
because i sued the writers guild because
i said that the rule was not fair
because if someone who's not the
producer rewrites a movie it's easier
for them to get
credited than if you're the producer and
you rewrite the movie and it's there to
protect people from getting screwed over
by producers
who are trying to get credit but it's
ultimately unfair because why should it
be a different yeah amount of work but
anyway so the cable guy bombs but i'm
suing the guild to get my name on it and
everyone needs to make
suing to get your name on the movie and
you did celtic pride too i did celtic
pride another underrated underrated
movie wow well the thing is colin quinn
wrote celtic bride and it was
it was not makable because he just had
all the nba players doing drugs and
there was gambling and like everything
in it would never get the nba she'll
allow it to be made to use the logos and
everything yeah you just couldn't do it
and it was really really funny
and
so i said can i take a pass at it and
see if i can get it makeable and the
funny thing about it is when we shot it
it was the last thing they did at boston
garden before they tore it down oh wow
they shot because
yeah and so that was one of those that
you know
it
totally was not what we hoped it would
be yeah you know and and we but also it
was so fun because we got to hang out at
boston garden like bob kuzie's there
like a lot of those people are around at
that time
and uh and it just you know didn't all
come together but
it was a great i i always felt bad
because
quinn wrote such a cool thing right you
know but it was just so edgy any time
you have a great idea of like football
and you're like and then the football
player is doing coke like you can't make
it really because you want to make up
the yeah but it's making up the teams
yeah you know remember they did well
they did it in uh that show an espn
playmakers back in the day and it was
like the sharks they're teams
so yeah because these aren't real
football teams but they're first
right right remember sports night that
was a great show that was good yeah
classic was that sorkin yeah oh only one
season i think damn i think it was too
smart for the room yeah well it came at
that weird time when i think you needed
a laugh track to be able to they were
like what is this it's just a situation
comedy without laughing well undeclared
i think suffered from that because they
weren't single camera comedy shows we
were on after like that 70s show we just
didn't fit in
anywhere
so
we just seemed odd there's all these
weird factors i feel like we're getting
out of that with internet a little bit
because you know back in the day was
like seinfeld only made it because they
put it on after cheers randomly you know
they probably wouldn't have caught steam
if it wasn't on after cheers and that
just took off but like
now with the internet it's just here you
go
whenever you want or apple tv or
streaming or whatever it's just there
yeah it's just sitting there well the
habit of tv sucks now because
you watch the whole show in a few days
and so it's
instead of 22 it's like six or eight and
you eat it up and then it disappears for
like two years yeah you don't remember
what it was yeah and then you eat it up
again and then it shows up two and a
half years later yeah like it was fun
like watching mash
every week because you had a
relationship with the show yeah it was
like part of your life and now uh it's
not like that and someone was telling me
that
they basically decided that the idea of
dropping it all at once really doesn't
work for the audience that they don't
like it they don't mind like dropping
two and next week dropping two like
maybe like not just one a week
but that
people like to be engaged for a couple
of months
i think so even if they're they want to
binge it they they know it's because you
forget like episode one yeah it's like
you want them all you don't remember the
first cookie when you're on number 11.
right you don't have that feeling
anymore yeah i'm a big curb nut and curb
would come out every sunday and it was
so did succession so it was like my big
night curb and succession the same night
sopranos and sopranos the promise was
like the godfather was coming out every
week
for like seven eight years we talked
about sopranos is our favorite show ever
you know what mad men's another one
where it's like it was every week but
also it was like two and a half years in
between seasons you'd be like these kids
are adults now what the hell right
they're aging in a very weird way and
sometimes like the end of one season
that the first episode the next season
is the next day and the kids grow in a
year and a half
[Laughter]
it's got a mustache all right we don't
want to keep you here because we know
you got the uh fallon are we already on
time
we're not because i have to go on the
tonight show right now and
and push things
and and try to be sharp well you were
this is a great episode uh i i'm i'm
only i've only read like four or five of
the interviews so far but i can't wait
to finish this great book yeah the first
one so i'm excited for this one yeah
love it it's really awesome and uh i
can't wait to see the movie man netflix
uh the bubble yeah bubble carlin dock
coming out in may and and i i know you
guys
know most of judd's work but you know we
have a lot of die-hard comedy nerds who
listen to this so this this is your demo
man yeah
before you go one comic you hate no
i'm sure i can find one besides cosby
yeah
thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we might
be
true
oh uh what a great episode guys thanks
for listening uh we got a bunch of road
dates coming up i'll be at the brea
improv
uh april 28th through 30th i'll be in la
that should that show sold out so then
we're going to add a second one small
venue but i'm sure we'll be doing
something in la together
the time uh
i'm adding oh this comes out the next
week wait a minute
adding what
oh i'm gonna add a uh i think a gotham
week oh oh that's a great idea yeah
um i don't want the stress of another
theater show i just want to do it
no no we got a zany's in nashville
albany
uh toronto it's a second show added
first one sold out we got a
providence chicago taping i hope to see
you there hell yeah at the den we got uh
i'm all over the place just just go to
the website i can't read anymore
cleveland tampa samurail.com shows love
you yeah
uh i'm i'm all over the road uh phoenix
at stand up live big room so come on out
great club great club colusa california
it's a casino lord knows that'll be
wacky denver some theater uh i think
it's called the paramount addison improv
comedy club in dallas love that room
love that town bricktown comedy club and
okc another great one yeah uh san jose
improv coming up huge huge room cool
down
yeah huge room uh oh stand up live in
huntsville
and
uh minneapolis i spent a week there one
night
pantages theater minneapolis chicago at
the vic cleveland
uh irvine
all kinds of good dates mark
normancomedy.com thanks for tuning in
make sure to uh tell your friends about
the pod i hope you enjoyed this one pick
up judge book it really is i'm only like
a few in it and it's
i can't speak into it into it it's great
the word is an eskimo
i'm inuit
a lot of great stuff uh today so uh yeah
we might be drunk pod at gmail.com if
you want to send us emails questions
uh bits yeah thanks for whatever you
want peeves whatever you want we'll take
it so tell a friend get on board have a
drink
or don't
and we'll see on the road